you
[Music]
this morning on the dish a woman who's
responsible for some of the best-looking
food on film born in Philadelphia Susan
Spungen turned a love of food into a
successful career as a magazine editor
producing cooking and styling creations
for Martha Stewart Living right from the
publication's very first issue then she
went from the page to the stage working
as a top Hollywood food consultants and
stylist on Julie and Julia Eat Pray Love
and other big productions and she's the
author of several cookbooks including
her highly anticipated latest open
kitchen inspired recipes for casual
gatherings Susan's pungen good morning
and welcome to the dish thank you it's
great to have you here tell us what's in
front of us well first we're going to
start with a couple of different toasts
because they're just an easy casual way
to start a meal and then we have the
winter citrus salad with avocado and all
kinds of different citrus and on diva
and then we have what I call pink pasta
it's not doesn't look totally pink today
but it has a lot of pink things in it
like the pseudo radicchio red onions and
then we have not fried it's called not
fried I love eggplant parm and our
dessert oh yes and then we have lemon
meringue bars for dessert fantastic so
when did you know that a food stylist
was even a job that you could pursue
well I didn't and this was pre social
media so I one day saw this article in
The New York Times and The New York
Times turns out to be very central to my
career arc but I read this article and
it was called how to make the basil
blush in 1990 and I was like wow this
sounds like a great job I really well
this sounds like it's for me the money
is good hours are good it's creative
it's fun I get to do food but in a
different way so I read that article and
then I started to pursue that path MMK
Martha Stewart Living right then that
led me actually to meeting Martha in a
kind of convoluted way that we don't
have time to get into nono just like
socially I met her PR person and and
then like a year after meeting her she
called me and said Marshall starting a
magazine and looking for food people and
probably I was the only food person
maybe she met and so
she called doesn't matter why and that
flute stylists don't get enough
attention and credit for what they do
and and the job talked a little bit
about what it is it involves well the
truth is there's a lot of different kind
of kinds of food styling you have people
who do food for magazines and then you
have people who do food for commercials
now sometimes there's crossover I've
done a little bit of everything but
there's just you know different levels
and different types of food styling
depending on what the job requires what
is it like when you are on a set so I
mentioned Julie and Julia Eat Pray Love
you think of those movies all you see is
the food and right what is it like to be
on those sets and trying to make your
creations
well last imagine that's like times 100
but you know there's a lot of factors
the kind of effect what you're doing and
usually you're kind of at the food
stylist the low man on the totem pole so
you're not hanging out with Meryl Streep
no no no I am and the fact I've had the
the pleasure and the the privilege of
working directly with the actors because
the films that I worked on the the actor
tattoo and or be cooking so like
especially on Julie and Julie I worked
really closely with Amy Adams and with
Meryl Streep I showed her how to flip an
omelet for the seams
you know and because they were food
movies right you know I'm not just doing
background food if I was just doing
background food I wouldn't have that
opportunity to interact for instance on
Julie and Julia I probably made the
French onion soup which is like a shot
that goes by like that ten times because
they kept scheduling it at the end of
the day every day they would be like oh
no we're wrapping your French onion soup
and we would do it again right all the
hats that you wear I mean could ask
gracious when do you have time to write
a book the film stuff the glow from the
films lasts a long time I haven't really
worked on a major feature for a few
years so what was that inspiration then
for the book for you oh for the book
well I just love sharing my cooking
philosophy and my food with the world
and I want people to cook more so this
is like sort of my post Martha food
philosophy because I I did work there
for a very long time so when I did my
first book
2005 it was kind of a little bit on the
heels of that and this is really me
because I've been we like you yeah you
sign the dish
okay and if you could have this meal
with anyone past or present who would it
be
well I've been thinking a lot lately
about Georgia O'Keeffe because like her
recipe book box is up on the auction
block right now and she was quite a cook
and I recently toured her kitchen in
Santa Fe or abiquiu and I was just loved
being in her kitchen so much and I wish
that she was still here to have a meal
with that Susan thank you go ahead and
sign because you have to see how
beautiful the signature is and if you
want more on Susan or the dish you can
head to our website
at CBS this morning calm